[Music]
the days of the andals were numbered
one by one their so-called kings were
bending the knee
or facing the wrath of aegon targaryen
aegon of old valyria aegon who was blood
of the dragon
when aegon came demanding fealty king
harren the black ruled as far
east as the trident other kings like the
starks could kneel
but haron was ironborn and the ironborn
must be beaten
in harrenhal he had the mightiest castle
in westeros
and the army to defend it but aegon did
not intend a siege
he mounted his dragon and roasted haron
and all his sons in their tower and the
old way with them
because of aaron's defiance aegon pushed
the ironborn back to our islands and
gave the riverlands to the tullys
but he did allow the ironborn to choose
who would lead them
the old river kings storm kings and the
kings of the rock
spilled blood here for thousands of
years
squabbling like children over a new toy
until the ironborn came and spanked them
with their axes
under harren the black their kingdom
stretched all the way to the god's eye
where they built the largest castle
westeros had
ever seen maesters teach that harren was
a fool
but he had some sense if you're going to
enslave and torture an entire people
you best have thick walls to hide behind
but the very day the last stone was laid
in harrenhal
aegon targaryen landed in westeros
awin horror born to a king who had a
fleet he didn't sail
and swords he didn't blood as an unruly
and worthless youngest son
harwin was sent away to the east to
vanish and so he did
but when his father died harin returned
to the island islands for the kingsmooth
an elder brother objected so an elder
brother fell of a horse
and at the with no man objected i will
launch his father's ships for westeros
and took
ten times the iron islands from its weak
lords who never expected to face an
ironborn
king as skilled on land as at sea for
harvan had reaped with eastern pirates
and
served with eastern sell swords and
learned more
war than the ironborn could imagine
after raygun and his dragons burned our
last king
aaron the black and broke our armies the
defeated ironborn chose my ancestor
reckon greyjoy as lord of the iron
islands
not king house baratheon was born in the
wars of
conquest when aegon the dragon invaded
westeros
aegon sent his commander orris baratheon
to take storm's end
argilac the arrogant the last of the
storm kings foolishly left the safety of
his stronghold
and met the baratheon warlord in open
battle
argilac was soundly defeated and orris
took his lands
his holdings and his daughter
horus was said to be a half-brother to
aegon targaryen
if this were true a little blood of the
dragon mingled with that of the stag
in those days the seat of house
baratheon is storm's end
a legendary keep raised in the age of
heroes
it overlooks shipbreakers bay where
legend has it that durran the first
storm king raised the keep with the aid
of bran the builder of house stark
forging a centuries-long connection with
the stormlands and the north
after aegon's conquest of the seven
kingdoms the baratheons remained loyal
enough to the crown while targaryen
kings
came and went but loyalty has its limits
after defeating the iron man at
harrenhal and slaying the last of the
storm kings
aegon and his sisters rhaenys and
visenya
set their sights on other prizes the
gold mines of the rock
and the fertile lands of the reach
king lauren lannister of the rock and
king mern gardener of the reach
foolishly thought their combined armies
could beat back the targaryen host
they rode forth together their proud
banners flapping in the wind
and faced off against aegon in a vast
golden field of wheat
the two kings commanded a massive force
of nearly sixty thousand
and it appeared the day was theirs until
aegon unleashed all
three of his dragons for the first and
only time
each beast was named after the valyrian
gods of aegon's forefathers
visenya rode veigar whose fiery breath
could melt armor
rainis rode miraxis whose jaws were big
enough to swallow a horse whole
greatest of all was balerion the black
dread
with fire dark as night and wings so
huge
whole towns were covered in shadow when
he flew overhead
this magnificent creature was written by
aegon himself
four thousand men were bathed in
glorious dragon flame that day
on what came to be known as the field of
fire
king mern was among the dead and house
gardener
died with him his stewards the tyrells
surrendered his ancestral stronghold of
highgarden to aegon
and were appointed lords paramount of
the reach
and wardens of the south when lauren
lannister witnessed mern's fate
he wisely bent the knee aegon spared
lauren's life and the lannisters were
made lords paramount of the westerlands
and wardens of the west
unlike the lannisters starks and aarons
we were never kings in our own right
house
gardener ruled the reach since the dawn
age
and we were their stewards while they
ward to enrich their already rich domain
we managed their castle of highgarden
but then aegon targaryen landed with his
dragons
nobody knows why the gardener king took
the field against him
anyone could see that a man who grows
flowers should beware a man who grows
fire-breathing monsters but maybe it
wasn't wholly his idea
maybe someone whispered in his ear about
all the
face he'd lose with the other six kings
if he stayed home
the rest is history the last gardener
king lost his face
along with his body and his steward
harlan terrell
promptly yielded highgarden to aegon my
grandmother swears that harlan was like
most of our men
and grew up banging steel together too
loudly for a thought to penetrate
but luckily his wife had better sense
whatever the case in return for harlan's
show of sense
aegon proclaimed house tyrell the lords
of the reach
and wardens of the south passing over
all the other houses with
better claims some great houses call us
upstarts
but the truth is that while the starks
and lannisters fell to the targaryens in
defeat
house tyrell rose for thousands of years
our family served as loyal stewards to
the kings of the reach
until the last of their line unwisely
burned to death
resisting the targaryen invaders
to save the reach from a similar fate we
yielded the castle of highgarden to
aegon
and his sisters in gratitude
the targaryens gave house tyrell
dominion over the reach
and we became lords of the castle in
which for generations we had served
when aegon the conqueror was earning his
name
house hightower traded its loyalty to
the gardeners
for his confirmation of their rights
welcoming him with
open arms and open gates
house hightower bent the knee to aegon
to spare the city from his dragons
i would think such insinuations and
insults beneath even you qyburn
and again mockery of one's bitters is
the trade of fools
i wouldn't know the starks reigned as
kings for
thousands of years even withstanding the
invasion of the andals
as the southern kingdoms fell and the
children of the forest were driven away
the north stood strong maintaining its
religious customs and its way of life
eventually the reign of the kings of
winter came to an
end with the coming of aegon the
conqueror
after aegon and his dragons destroyed
the combined armies of the reach in the
rock
at the field of fire king tauren stark
bent the knee and swore fealty to the
targaryen dynasty
in order to spare the destruction of
winterfell and his people
he was forever after known as the king
who knelt
as a reward for his submission aegon
named tauren
lord of winterfell and warden of the
north
aegon the conqueror arrived in westeros
house aaron bent the knee to aegon and
his dragons
and were allowed to maintain the control
of the region
as lords paramount of the veil and
wardens of the east
king's landing is both a city and a
curse
aegon the conqueror was the first king
to land there
his first conquest a tiny village at the
mouth of the blackwater river where he
raised a wooden fort
when it became clear that aegon would
earn his title
people flocked to the fort and renamed
it king's landing in his honor
the ploy succeeded and aegon chose
king's landing for his capital over
older and more
beautiful cities like old town and
anywhere else the carrying of royal
favor thus
became the foundation of the city and
blood its bricks
eventually after centuries of courtship
house martel
got into bed with the targaryens we took
king daeron ii and his sister for our
own before they could take each other
and six kingdoms became seven even now i
do not blame my ancestors
one look at those long silver locks
it is not every day a man gets to ride a
dragon
aegon's conquest was assured in a short
time
the so-called seven kingdoms were melted
down in the heat of the dragon's flame
and transformed into a single realm
aegon would forever be known as aegon
the conqueror